kyle freeland as you mentioned has
thrown the ball very well against la
this year 1-1 from freeland to seeger
smacked it right through the base hit
right past krone
seeger continues his assault on kyle
freeland and the dodgers with the base
hit with one out
ball four two on
[Applause]
he's swinging and he pops it up great
for the rocky story battle of the sun
makes the catch and kyle freeland worked
out of a little pickle in the first max
scherzer we don't have to hand out his
resume to everybody i think you know
what he has accomplished a first ballot
hall of fame career already if he never
throws another bullet but in many
respects
this season is his best season
rogers out on strikes let's strike out
number one for scherzer today joggers
have to be more patient than they were
in the opening frame
aj [ __ ] first time back rips one into
the left field corner aj around first on
his way to second nice and easy with a
lead off first pitch stand up double
yeah curveball in the subaru super mode
you know that front foot gets out there
a little bit he really kept the body
quiet and stayed behind that baseball
and that's allowed him to still stay
through it and hit the double austin
barnes will try to get pollock over at
least 90 feet maybe get him in all the
way
breaking the hit to the right side
that's through
aj around third on his way to the plate
and pollock slides in safely the dodgers
strike first this afternoon it's one
nothing
austin barnes with an rbi basic even if
he made the out would it advance the
runner over to third base well it does
even better than that just a perfect
swing
and the other good news aj pollock goes
from second to home under some pressure
slides
and he's okay
two one
on the ground right side to throw a base
hit
deluxe with another hit and barnes will
stop at second
now corey seeger will come up one for
one
okay let's run into right here that's
gonna be a base hit
the barn scores and here comes ruxin
right behind him
three nothing dodgers on a two-out
two-round single for corey seeger
and seeger somehow the bat did not break
not a bad pitch in fact that pitch is
off the plate inside another swing at
what would have been a ball trevor story
leads off
this is going to be a base hit for
trevor
[Applause]
lead off single first base runner for
the rockies
there goes story and it's a base hit the
other way so trevor will cut the bag and
go to third
and the rockies have two on no one out
here in the second down three nothing
sam hilliard facing scherzer for the
first time in his career
2-1 that's a base hit right center field
story will score crow will easily go to
third sam loves striding into second and
the rockies getting after back scherzer
here in any number two the dodgers
scored three
and now the rockies are answering this
is another change up they're doing a
nice job on the change out today the
rockies early on
making sure that they don't try to pull
it too much
2-2
and he gets hampton
a pull-pull guy and he hits it the other
way this is a long run for pollock who
has a bad wheel he's going to get there
and crow just does not run well enough
to
try to score on that so kyle freeland
will try and help himself
and this ball to left it he'll drop
one run his score here comes hillary
he is safe at the play kyle freeland
ties it up
this is where i i think too that little
gimpy hamstring out left field for aj
pollock didn't allow him to come in and
make this catch
solid swing from kyle
and then when he had to sit back there's
no way he is going to be able to throw
out sam hilliard at home that's four
rbis on the season for cotton ryan
mcmahon the third baseman
out on strikes
mcmahon gone strikeout number three for
with
scherzer
strikeout max scherzer has now tied
justin verlander for 18th all time on
the strikeout list
he's also caught him
as far as strikeouts by active pitchers
2-2 on the way to hampson
got him swinging
number
four
that's a chase right there
four
and scherzer who never walks a soul
has walked freeland to lead off the
fifth and now ramel toppy at the plate
oh this is hammer to right take a good
look you won't see it for long
one
topia
two-run home run
and it has been a while
[Applause]
five three
rockies
[Applause]
still
still watching it
hitting streak one for two of the walk
today
and he's got another hit
should bring the tying run up
two hits for turner
aj pollock at the plate and the pitch
right field of base hit turner's gonna
come around easily and score
and rumbling around first and on his way
to second with his second double of the
game is aj pollock and the dodgers have
cut it to a run the dodgers even though
they've struggled with winners in score
position after the second inning today
have yet another run that can pick up
here tying run at second and pollock
[Applause]
he's gonna get him fly ball to center
field
so a run for the dodgers
and it's a 5-4 affair middle of eight
top of the ninth inning carlos estevez
looking for three out
and he swings and lying to the right
fail a base hit and here comes the
one-two to seeger
swings hits the ball and kicks off of
estevez and rolls out toward left field
grabbed by story
and we continue now the tying run in
scoring position we'll see what trey
turner can do
left side that's through for a basement
monkey around third coming to the plate
he will score and tie the game
it's five to five
trey turner with his third hit of the
afternoon
and that's muncie was over four looking
to do some extra innings damage against
the lefty gilbert here we go in the tent
matt swings and he hits a high drive to
centerfield this ball is back his ball
is gone daddy gone
and extra innings home run for max
muncie
and the dodgers
instant offense in the 10th
lead this game 7-5
and for muncie
it was in the ball game gets a pitch
right down the middle
and over the 415
foot sign and into the babbling freak
and the rockies with a tying run on and
the potential winning run coming to the
plate
2-0
the ground ball to the right side
turner's got it flips the secret one
onto first
double play
and the dodgers win it 7-5 in extra
innings